eighty percent of people could care less
about your problems
twenty percent of people are glad you
have them it's the game we signed up for
and
the game we all signed up for is what
it's called life
people are gonna die there's gonna be
divorces they're gonna be losses
if you play the game of business you're
going to lose money there's going to be
risk
there's going to be enemies there's
going to be people that want to see you
go out of business
it's a part of life it's painful i get
it but
we signed up and we're in this life
[Music]
now i'll tell you my story i'm coming up
when i'm coming up and i'm building my
insurance agency
in october 29th of
uh 2010 get a call from glenn beck
and glenn beck calls me says hey i'd
like to talk to like glenn vick okay
cool i had a radio show called saving
america back then
with uh same place with hugh hewitt and
dennis prager and some of these guys
so beck calls me says um yeah i want you
to uh fly out to uh uh
uh new york to be on fox because we hear
what you're doing and we want you to be
on we have a program with entrepreneurs
you ought to come out i'm like wow okay
so i went out
and then i went on fox news on 2010
that's 10 years ago
and i spoke and i'm not yet involved in
politics like i'm not even i'm 30 years
old at the time 31 32 years old at the
time
i come back my san francisco office
shutdown
which was 18 of my revenue at the time i
had my
office in san fernando valley that shut
down which was 11
of my revenue overnight from being on
fox news with glenn beck i lost 30
of my revenues wow okay yeah and
i couldn't afford it at the time so it
almost put me out of business
i came back i said pat shut down the
show
i turn it off just stick to business and
entrepreneurship
i did behind closed doors and smaller
settings i would talk about it
but when it came down to the bigger
setting i didn't talk about it
eventually what happened my outlet
i stuck to economy i stuck to economy
and i i i'm not fully where i will share
with you everything on how i think about
politics
i wrote a fiction book that took me five
years to write
96 000 words that i still haven't
published that if i publish the world
would think i'm crazy i'm not going to
publish it i'm going to publish after i
sell majority of my shares here
then maybe i'll publish the book and
i'll put it out on what i really think
about half the time
because some people are going to say pat
a little bit out there uh
moral the story today
i openly talk about politics have you
noticed that that i'm more comfortable
today talking about politics than a year
ago than two years ago than three years
ago
do you know why because i don't need
any of your money on here none of your
money
this is you guys you're not like
valuetainment is not
i don't know valuetainment is not
five percent of my income not one
percent of my income i attempt maybe one
percent of my net worth
i don't know if that made sense and i'm
not insulting only reason i'm saying
this to you i have the power
and the leverage of not needing the
money
so the other day coca-cola calls us and
leo handles this account we get a call
out of nowhere from coca-cola
and coca-cola cmo uh
hires me to be their uh consultant
so i don't know if it's this week or
next week i'm having a call with them
and they pay
premium because it's gonna this week
okay so it's this week
and leo dealt with them and they got
them going and i'm gonna be working with
them and their executives to help
their marketing team identify their next
five moves
they say a price we give the price they
say yes their team had read the book
boom we do business together whether
they say yes or no i don't need that
money
because i built a business that's
generating income so you have to be
thinking about
if you're fully ready to make that move
or not i don't want to give you the
naive move to say go talk about what you
believe in and all of a sudden you lose
your 2.7 million i don't want to do that
to you you know so
if you do have aspirations long term
remember
your next 15 moves maybe talking
politics will be your next 11 move
your move 11 but not right now so just
be patient with it hold yourself back a
little bit
and then release your thoughts when you
have 510 million in the bank and you're
more confident and you're not relying on
one source of income
this is my mo there are certain people
that don't believe in this but i do i
think you got to find a way to have
carrots in your life to get you excited
and recreate yourself
i think you need to have some kind of
carrots you know i
i the whole concept of
capitalism is based on incentives so if
there's no incentives capitalism
doesn't work so you're a capitalist you
got to put some kind of incentives for
you and your wife what could that be i
don't know
you know it could be anything uh but uh
i understand delayed gratification i'm
all for it i'm all for delayed
gratification i said this the other day
and and hopefully this will make sense
to you i currently right now i've been
living in a
million and a half i just sold my house
four million
six five something like that right i
don't live in a ridiculous house
i live in an 8 300 square foot house but
i told myself
babe i don't want to go from one and a
half
to three million dollar house i don't
want to go from one and a half to five
million dollar house
i just want to skip like four levels so
i told her i said i'm not going to be
buying a big house we can live in a
house like this
but now we're going from a one and a
half million dollar house to potentially
a 20 million dollar house
because i would delayed gratification
for a few years now at the same time
i've had the lambos the ferraris the the
porsches the
uh uh rolls-royce the all those cars
because that's my incentive i like that
i buy a expensive card because i like
that i enjoy doing those kinds of things
that's a different conversation on
incentives i think you're talking about
whether i need to be taking income or
not because i'd rather invest it back
into the company
it all depends on how big of a thing you
want to do in the next year two years
three years
but if eventually you and your wife
don't see an incentive
specifically your wife like she needs to
see some incentives
she may not be wired like you she may
need to see incentives to kind of see
this thing that
you're working so hard there's a there's
a reason behind the madness
[Music]
we've never done a uh uh
ever we've never done a organization
recruiting the staffing agency
recruiting for the field
we've always used recruiting agencies
for home office
always yep multiple staff and for home
office
never for the field that's been 100 war
market
and that's worked very very well for us
now obviously
you have to also know that we get a lot
of leads that come through
uh php's youtube channel or
people see a video from me on
valuetainment and then they say what
does this guy do oh my gosh i've always
wanted to get into insurance and then
boom
they send an information and that goes
out and somehow some way they get
involved
but we don't have a place we go through
we get the leads we just have a
ridiculous system
that we've trained our guys on a warm
market that's worked very well
and if you do that right it could work
very well for you a lot of people use
leads
we don't today if you're looking at
young guys i mean instagram today is the
number one recruiting tool out there
hands down there's not a better tool in
recruiting today than instagram
it's specifically for sales guys and
girls
so but but the part you got to be
thinking about is the following let me
flip it on you a little bit
the com structure of many companies
will determine whether the sales people
will recruit
or they will sell where you put your
incentives
is where your sales people will go bring
new talent for you
so if a part of your incentive is pre
based on
me recruiting talent i'm going to
recruit more talent for you i was
consulting this
uh a trucking company and
they were doing you know 5 million a
year you know 10 million a year business
and i went out there one day and we
worked on their comp plan for an entire
day we spent one full day on their comp
plan one full day under complex
and we came back and we put a comm
structure together for them
2020 they ended up with a quarter of a
billion dollars of sales but they but
their
sales in all and all they changed
is they changed the incentive for their
branch managers that they have
and they started bringing in guys that
started selling loads and the next thing
you know now they have branches in
us mexico canada europe armenia
all over the place and they're doing
around a quarter of a billion dollars a
year
you got to kind of look at your comp
plan and see where the incentive could
be for your sales guys to be recruiting
versus just selling if you look at if
you look at a guy's kids
on how the kid does whatever he does
look look at kids of teachers you guys
ever noticed kids of teachers
if you know a teacher in your family
that's a older teacher like let's just
say in their 60s
and they have three or four kids what do
their kids do
how many of your kids got a four-year
degree why
because the teachers number one
incentive and the families to do what
get good grades
now you look at an entrepreneur's kids
what's the incentives
it's a very different incentive system
so whatever incentive you create i
guarantee you your kids are going to go
after those incentives
your sales guys are going to go through
those incentives so
test your incentive system i changed my
comp structure
probably 50 times in the first 24 months
finally i hit a sweet spot and then i
just said oh my gosh this one's gonna
take off
and then it took off i just had a
meeting with my guys and i announced to
them
on the first my announcement was uh
top 30 performers in a company
for 21st to 30th place i'm getting
everybody a cash corvette c8 i buy for
them uh uh
11th through the 20th i get them a
porsche 911 and i fly them out to uh
germany to go pick out the porsche
second to tenth place i'm getting
everybody a cash brand new ferrari
portofino
and in first place i'm getting you cash
avenador and i'm flying you out to
lamborghini headquarters to get this for
you right okay now watch this in
order for me to buy those five million
dollars worth of cars
the company has to grow 40 if we grow 40
five million is nothing to me you you
understand what i'm saying like fine
chris
i'll spend a five million bucks and you
have no idea how crazy people are going
right now
guys if we do this i'm gonna do this if
we do this i'm gonna do this so there's
a relationship where
one of the most important trainings i
ever did for my before my company is the
following
i said let's talk about here's how it
opened up uh and this is something all
of you guys can do
i said it was a four-hour session i had
with my guys i sat in
my room in woodland hills and i said
guys um
i want you here long term and i want you
to give your best
but before i give you that what is your
expectation of me
what do you expect from me as a ceo and
at first they start very
soft like small stuff well you know
uh we would like this from you okay
great
we would like that we would like you to
be responsible financially okay great
we were like this or we would like you
to add millions in the comp one day we
would like you to
we will look okay so they said we would
like you we would like you we would like
you we would like to
and then it got bigger which was great
because it set me up for what
i said perfect in order for me to be
able to give this from you is it fair to
say that i should have some expectations
of you as well
yes i said i got a powerpoint prepared
of what i expect from you in order for
you to get what you get
and this can be a very simple
relationship together let me go through
it with you
boom boom boom two-hour powerpoint i
went through on exactly what i expected
from now
so then everybody understood you want
this let's do this
you want this let's do this you want
that's what helped us grow and i think
sometimes the relationship between
the supervisor the ceo the boss and
their people it's not like that
so you screw it up but if you come from
and you have to let them talk first not
you
you have to be sensitive and addressing
the most
uncomfortable topics way before you hire
them number one
like i said do you want a salary or do
you want to be a consultant i don't want
to be a consultant then if your salary
you have to report i'm good with that
then if you report there's
accountability i'm good with that so but
that
can't be like oh my gosh we're gonna
take over the world together let's go
oh [ __ ] we're fighting we're having
problems no no no no no like
slow down and take a few more weeks
before you do this but ask
all the difficult questions and sora and
it's it's
the closest thing to a prenuptial
agreement you can have and i don't know
if you have a nuptial agreement or not
i'm all about nuptial agreements it's
the closest thing to an optional
agreement you can have
and i'm i'm 100 fan of nuptial
agreements i recommend it to every man i
know that has money and then his
incentive the way it's set up you gotta
comp
for salary benefits all the other stuff
you negotiate then it's
you know 20 bonus 25 bonus whatever the
bonus
will be based on markers what are
markers if he hires this person for me
if he raises this much money if the
ebitda is around this number if we grow
out a 40
rate whatever if we if we if we if we if
we whatever those markers are going to
be
then he knows what he has to hit if he
doesn't hit it he doesn't get that 25
bonus so if you pay him a salary of i
don't know pick a number
uh uh for the sake of easy math let's
just use a hundred thousand dollars
obviously you have to pay more than a
hundred before
sake of math if you use a hundred
thousand dollars and you say i'm gonna
pay an additional fifty percent of
bonuses great
divided amongst five different uh areas
ten percent if the company grows by
forty percent net profit so we're doing
a million dollars this year
if we grow and do one point four million
you hit your ten thousand dollar bonus
great next
i need a ceo i need a director of
finance and i need a controller
if you find those three that's another
ten thousand dollars great
three i need to expand into two new
markets and if you help us grab
expensive great
boom i need the office to be
restructured set up and you know
lease everything bathrooms okay great so
you create whatever those markers are
with the incentives
he's got his date today plus those five
incentives that gives them the
additional 25
bonus and inequity will be based on
investing period he's going to want
three years you're going to want five
years
you'll settle on four years he may agree
to five years you may have to agree on
three years because this guy's just
better than you and you're gonna have to
work to get a relationship you know
calling him out
you can't undermine him you know you
can't talk to him like a boss see
somebody that's self-made but behind
closed doors if you can
how's accountability going to work out
all of that matters
here's the kicker you know what's crazy
about lying half the battle with line is
you're trying to avoid conflict yes
you're trying to avoid conflict or
you're trying to avoid the uh
uh embarrassment or you want to look
cooler you know you know the whole thing
where
guys will say they've been with three
times the girls they've been with and
girls will say three times less than the
guys they've really been we ever heard
that uh story before
scientists have done extensive research
on this so don't call me out and say pat
had a
you know moment where he's calling out
women but
why do men say three times because they
want to be three times cooler
why do women say three times less
because they want to be embarrassed less
right to say well i haven't really gone
and full-run as much as i have okay
so that's not going away just so you
know that now there's a difference
between that
and lies like that or
you have a commitment to hit you don't
hit it that's a problem okay
that's a problem there's a difference
between that
and you know
a compliance lie you can you can take a
company down with a compliance slide
there's a difference between that and
but i call out the behavior
because i don't tolerate the behavior i
don't tolerate manipulative behavior
i don't tolerate games and i don't
tolerate anything that's going to hurt
the company
and bring others down so the more you
talk about it sometimes
the challenge uh assignment is your
values and principles to the field or
your
employees or your executive team is not
clear
if they don't know your set of values
and principles and you don't
talk about it over and over and over and
over and over and over again
then they don't know what your
expectations are right they're kind of
like
i don't know what it takes to make simon
happy i don't know what's a good
employee
i don't know what's a good partner i
don't know what's a good executive
i don't know what's a good investor
because you've never had those values
and principles so how do you do that
well you take a piece of paper and a
sunday afternoon or saturday afternoon
and you sit down and say what are the
best
employees i've ever had make a list of
what made them the best
what do you love most about johnny
jackie larry mary
and then who were the employees
or what kind of behavior hurt the
company the most
and what setback the company the most
okay
what were those behaviors which one of
those behaviors will you not tolerate
great then guess what go tell the
stories
what i give them specific names go tell
the stories
then i'm going to sit there and i'm
going to say oh
i do that sometimes okay i got to work
on that
oh i do that sometimes he likes that
awesome i got a shot here
oh phenomenal he loves that that's me
he's talking about me i don't think this
company is for me i gotta go
it's okay it's okay
but you gotta share your values and
principles i read a book a few months
ago called no rules rules and i had
every one of my employees read the book
norah's rules and i had them read what
measure what matters
and after everybody read no rules rules
we kind of sat down and we went through
the process of what everybody was saying
what i was saying
kind of figured out some people just
don't belong here in the culture and i'm
not changing
i'm not changing because if i have to
conform to you i never had a real
culture
i didn't take time to really process
what my culture was
the moment you do that then they'll know
what to respond to but if they don't
you keep it a secret no one knows what's
bothering and what's not and by the way
if i lose safe around you and you want
me to be around with your long term
if you don't allow me to save face i
will leave you because you offended me
so you you also got to make sure you're
not
you know hey papa you know you're not
coming out just like
i don't care what happens you know now
you don't want to do that you got to let
me save face because i'm going to make
more mistakes
you know if i don't have that
opportunity for people to say face
sometimes you need a crisis to
get create even more loyalty with your
employees i don't know if this makes
sense
sometimes you need a problem where we
overcome together
then the team's like this that's why so
many people when they go to war together
their level of bond is
the kind that they'll never have with
their wives or husbands or you know
kids it's different we went to work
together we almost died together
we were so annoyed with each other
because somebody screwed up but we
overcame that
when we came back safe and we saved
lives you have to give that
opportunity for people as well work you
on yourself on a leader make a note of
what you won't tolerate what you like
what's been qualities of your best
employees give that message to your guys
then go talk to that person help them
save face and help them save their ego
and then challenge them to improve and
then go about your business
[Music]
it's all on what kind of a culture you
want to create
because if it's external there is no
culture
okay it's just a transactional based
right it's like i'm not emotionally
connected to
you division any of this i'm just like
okay you're paying me i do the job we go
right if it's internal i'm vested
it's a culture i'm in it i'm around you
i'm like oh my gosh here's what we're
doing i love it
i want to be part of this i think this
is what we stand for here's what we do
as a company
so you know the risk of
one internal what's the risk
takes a lot more time right the
the benefit is what increases value when
it comes down to sell
it's it's very value based because
somebody sees a culture that's already
in there with leaders that are vested
that are not going to go
okay what's the benefit of two more
scalable
it's external it's easier right what's
the risk
people can come and go and it's turnover
is going to be higher because
you're just another boss you're just
another person that's paying them the
bills
so i think the question you got to
answer with that one is what's your
vision
and solve it based on that you know
right now my guys are working out of
home i'm not a fan of that
however you know
one of my it guys came up to me i love
this one my best hires of last year
he came up to me he was with aig for 26
years
quality guy quality guy he said
pat you got to realize there's a big
difference between the i.t
industry people and other types of
people that you hire in different
departments
he says i.t or career we come in
we like to stay with a company because
we want to finish the problem that we
started to work on we want to solve that
problem and we'll stay there it says
most i.t guys if they go to a company
they take care of them they'll stay with
them for a long time
uh because you know we kind of want to
continue solving a problem
he said the rest of the people that you
have in different departments they're
here because they have a job
he says i'm here for my career others
are here for their jobs
okay external is a lot of jobs
internal is career okay which one's
going to increase the value for you
solve for that okay solve for that i
would tell you right now as you're going
through the transition probably you need
a little bit of both
okay to do as we're going through the
phase that we're going through right now
but um the question will be answered
with that based on what your vision is
long term
[Music]
i interviewed a guy a couple weeks ago
was a cardiologist and he has done 25
000 heart
uh surgeries okay and this last week i
interviewed cyril wecht i don't know if
you guys know what cyril wecht is
sarah white is a number one pathologist
in america he's the guy that
he's he's done 21 000 autopsies okay
brains
and he supervised 41 000 of it you know
what's part of his game
is to hold brains and to deal with dead
people you know what's a part of a
cardiologist job
unfortunately his job is to sometimes go
to families and say what
we lost your father we lost your auntie
we lost your mom we lost your dad we
lost your husband we lost your wife we
lost your kid
and guess how many times the first time
you do it painful
tense time painful 50th time
painful by the 500 time
it's the career you chose some surgeries
don't go right
and you have to go deliver the news i'm
sorry but we lost your father
you ever seen a movie uh uh uh john q
where the whole heart thing and you saw
one of the heart surgeons in the movie
john q with denzel washington
where the way the doctor speaks he's so
logical i don't know if you guys know
what i'm talking about
yes okay so here's what we got going on
we got this and the way they speak is
very matter of fact
and the rest of the world is like what a
cold mother you know what
how could you be this cold this is
someone's life
because that's his job his job is
people die okay and the first one sucks
the fifth one sucks the tenth one sucks
by the fifty one is the career you chose
right okay
what does that have to do with you
um in football when there's a massive
injury in a game players psychologically
get afraid
if you if you look at football like
coaches and great coaches in that moment
have to get their players to realize
this is the game we signed up for you
could get hurt
but if you play right or not if you play
afraid of being injured the chance of
you getting injured goes higher
if you play as if you're not going to
get injured the chance of you getting
injured goes lower
that moment what the coach tells us
athletes
is what gets the players to go back out
there and play after a guy just broke
his leg he's gone for one year
it's that few right kobe came back after
having the whole achilles heel and how
does he go back
it's the game we signed up for and the
game we all signed up for is what it's
called life
people are going to die if you play the
game of business it's going to be
enemies there's going to be people that
want to
see you go out of business it's a part
of life so i i
i i don't want to seem like i'm not
being empathetic or sympathetic
believe me i cried when i'm sitting
there and watching my wife cry of course
i cry
it's painful i get it but we signed up
and we're in this life okay and however
many years ago all our parents conceived
and nine months later we're here some of
us are accidents some of us are
intentional but guess what
we're now here okay and we got around
eight years to see what we can do with
our lives nothing's guaranteed
we got to give our best but i want you
to know and this message goes to
everybody
is grace for impact there's going to be
some bad things that are going to happen
to you in 2021
not trying to be negative there's going
to be some bad things that are going to
happen to you
there's going to be some things that are
going to happen to you that you don't
know about my dad's 78
he's not going to live 200 years old
something's going to happen to me i'm no
longer 22 i'm 42.
okay i got three kids they're going to
get him to fight injuries something like
that i don't have one kid i don't have
zero kids i told the guy the other day
when the whole jack ma was being uh uh
kidnapped
in in china is he kidnapped is he this
is he that what happened to jack ma
i said you know what's one of the uh one
of the biggest mistakes people make in
life
that gives an automatic control to
politicians to be able to manipulate you
for the rest of your life what's that
having kids why because
if people want to really hurt you they
go straight to what
kids like in politics if you don't do
this
this is what's gonna happen to your kids
how do they eliminate the kennedy family
they went straight after their kids
so what's the point we all made the
decision
to be married if you are your heart's
going to be broken if you have kids
something could happen to your kid if
you eat the food and it's too much sugar
bad diet you may have something to do
with your heart
everything is a decision that we're
making and we got to do our best to live
with this
now here's also some guaranteed news
about 2021 there's going to be some
great things that are going to happen to
you in 2021
new surprises you're going to meet
someone they knew that you didn't know
before that's going to change your life
a new friend a new contact a new client
a new sales person a new employee
something good is going to happen a lot
of good is going to happen to you and
that's going to happen
every single year for the rest of our
lives
until it's time for us to go away that's
kind of how life works
but if you wake up every morning afraid
that
you know what if this what if that and
oh my gosh sorry me
feel sorry for me you are gonna stun so
much of your growth
because that's not going away and
everybody else in the world is dealing
with their own set of problems i read a
quote one time
eighty percent of people could care less
about your problems
twenty percent of people are glad you
have them
very simple eighty percent could care
less about your problems
twenty percent of your people are glad
you have an exes
former friends former employees
former workers are glad you're getting
your friends you gotta live your life
and you do your best and good things
will happen to you